♪.
RACHEL: A TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD
SOLDIER IS FEARED DEAD AFTER
RISKING HIS LIFE AND JUMPING
INTO THE RIO GRANDE TO SAVE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO WE NOW
KNOW WERE DRUG SMUGGLING
SUSPECTS.
THE STORY YOU'VE SEEN HERE, BUT
LIKELY NOWHERE ELSE, AS THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS LARGELY
IGNORED THE STORY.
FORMER U.S. BORDER PATROL CHIEF
RODNEY SCOTT IS HERE TO REACT.
RODNEY, SO GREAT HAVING YOU HERE
TODAY.
>> GOOD MORNING.
HOW FRUSTRATING FOR YOU TO KNOW,
OUTSIDE OF FOX NEWS AND OTHER
CONSERVATIVE OUTLETS VIRTUALLY
NO ONE COVERED THE DEATH OF THIS
HERO?
ONE MAINSTREAM MEDIA OUTLET
COVERED IT FOR 22 SECONDS, THE
REST ZERO.
>> EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING.
IT IS DEMORALIZING TO THE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS.
THEY'RE DOWN THERE, NATIONAL
GUARD, TEXAS PPS, FRUSTRATING TO
LOCAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
I TALKED TO A FEW AS FAR AS
NEW MEXICO, THE LACK OF
COVERAGE, THE LACK OF CARING IS
JUST MIND-BOGGLING TO MOST.
BIDEN SAID HE WOULD HAVE A MORE
HUMANE BORDER.
THIS IS NOT HUMANE IN ANY WAY,
SHAPE OR FORM.
RACHEL: NO, THEY'RE IS NOTHING
COMPASSIONATE ABOUT THIS POLICY
AT ALL.
NOW WE'RE HEARING THAT THIS
SOLDIER ACTUALLY SAVED DRUG SMUG
LERS.
THAT IS THE ISSUE WE DON'T KNOW
WHO IS COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
SAVING CHILDREN, SAVING PREGNANT
WOMEN, SAVING YOUNG AND OLD MEN
BUT IN THIS CASE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT DRUG SMUGGLERS.
>> YEAH.
I THINK IT REALLY HIGHLIGHTS THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE BORDER.
SOME PEOPLE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE BORDER, ONLY SHOP PICTURES,
CALL PEOPLE ASYLUM-SEEKERS, SHOW
THE FAMILIES COMING ACROSS BUT
THE ENTIRE BORDER IS CONTROLLED
BY THE CARTEL.
NOTHING CROSSES THE BORDER
WITHOUT THE CARTEL CROSSING IT.
AGENTS HAVE NO IDEA WHO THEY'RE
ENCOUNTERING UNTIL THEY HAVE
HANDS ON.
OUR BORDERS ARE COMPLETELY OUT
OF CONTROL NOW.
WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT THE WAVE
OF MIGRATION AND TITLE 42 IF
THAT GOES AWAY.
THAT WAVE IS ALREADY HERE.
THERE ARE CRIMINALS, TERRORISTS
MIXED IN.
OUR NATION IS AT RISK.
NOTHING STAYS IN THE BORDER.
GOING TO A TOWN WHERE VIEWERS
LIVE IN RIGHT NOW.
THEY GO EVERYWHERE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IGNORES
IT.
DOESN'T EVEN HAVE THE COURTESY
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE DEATH OF A
SOLDIER.
RACHEL: NO.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU LOOK AT THE
AMOUNT OF TIME, WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS MORNING, RODNEY, TIME SPENT
ON A FALSE STORY ABOUT BORDER
PATROL WHIPPING HAITIAN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
TURNED OUT TO BE FALSE.
NEVER APOLOGIZED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THAT.
IGNORING OF THE PRESS AND BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, DEMOCRAT
LAWMAKERS WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
POOR SOLDIER.
DO WE KNOW, HIS KIN HAS BEEN
INFORMED.
DO WE KNOW ANYTHING FURTHER
ABOUT THIS.
THEY STILL SEARCHING FOR THE
BODY?
WHAT IS THE LATEST?
>> THE LATEST INFORMATION I HAVE
FROM TEXAS IS THEY ARE STILL
SEARCHING.
I'M NOT DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN THE
NOTIFICATION, SO I WON'T GO ANY
FARTHER WITH THAT.
I DO KNOW THAT BOTH TEXAS DPS
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, THE
NATIONAL GUARD OFFICE IS HEAVILY
INVOLVED BUT I DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER FOLLOW-UP INFORMATION ON
THAT.
THIS IS ANOTHER TRAVESTY COULD
HAVE BEEN PREVENTED IF WE WOULD
HAVE CONTINUED TO SECURE THE
BORDER LIKE WE HAVE IN EVERY
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION.
THIS ADMINISTRATION JUST
COMPLETELY WALKED AWAY FROM
AMERICA.
WALKED AWAY FROM BORDER
SECURITY.
RACHEL: YEAH.
IT IS AN ABSOLUTE TRAGEDY.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
AS YOU RIGHTLY MENTIONED.
WE HAVE FLIGHTS THAT WERE GOING
OUT JUST YESTERDAY IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT, DROPPING PEOPLE
OFF, ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY, WITH
NO, WITH NO INFORMATION BEING
GIVEN TO MAYORS OR GOVERNORS OF
WHO AND WHAT IS DONE UNDERCOVER,
MEANT TO BE AWAY FROM THE EYES
OF PUBLIC.
THEY KNOW THE PUBLIC DOESN'T
LIKE IT.
THEY'RE DOING IT ANYWAY.
WE SEE THIS, THIS HORRIBLE,
HORRIBLE TRAGEDY.
WE WILL HONOR THAT YOUNG MAN.
UNTIL WE FIND HIS BODY WE'LL
PRAY FOR HIM AND HIS FAMILY.
WE THANK YOU, RODNEY SCOTT, FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING, PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE LACK OF RESPECT
ESPECIALLY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT